all right everyone's talking about this
new chainsaw man let's see what this
Show's all about
it
chainsaw man easily the most anticipated
new anime to come out all year the show
that we weren't ready for that would
come down and grace us showing us
peasants once and for all what good
anime is so how hard did chainsaw man
hit when it dropped
[Music]
yeah pretty [ __ ] hard as expected
it's taken over the community by storm
and with all this extra attention comes
the extra scrutiny after just one
episode was out already all the doubters
banded together experts and scientists
poured in thousands of man hours to
collectively construct the perfect
critique confident that their words
would be so severe the chainsaw man
fandom would be put in their place and
the whole anime Community would see the
error of their ways here's what they
came up with
chainsaw man fans have still not
recovered to this day but do the haters
have a point did the anime live up to
the expectations that
deal anime fans have been eating good
this year but you know what they could
be eating even better with our sponsor
today boxu weebs tell me did you get fed
well enough in 2022 don't lie to me
weaves unless you have your own box suit
boxu is my favorite Japanese snack box
it's a subscription service that sends
you a new box of goodies every single
month right from Japan they work with
family businesses all over Japan so you
know this is the good stuff they're
giving you guys I'm not gonna lie my
Christmas is canceled until boxers sent
me their gifts of snacks Christmas
dinners get out of here I'm eating well
because I got my own box too guys and
this is a month I'm super excited about
because this month is Hokkaido
Wonderland and if you know anything
about Japanese food any of the food that
comes from Hokkaido is chef's kiss
Godzilla you know what I'm gonna treat
myself by having a snack right now what
I got here is the white milk Boucher
let's give this a go
whoa I'm going to be honest I've already
eaten the snack on trash taste and I
wanted to eat it again because it was so
good I also wanted to try some Hokkaido
milk Tarantino crisps if there's one
thing that's really famous about
Hokkaido it's their milk so I've got
high expectations of this
oh smells good
oh this is really addicting oh I need
another one already one package is not
gonna be enough oh no guys it's the end
of the year it's the season of gifts and
giving so show someone close to your
Love Today by giving them a box so you
know they are gonna be eaten well so
click the link in the description and
use code to Gig up for 15 off your first
boxu order thank you very much the boxy
for sponsoring us today back to the
video it's no secret that I'm already a
big fan of the author so external
factors aside I was already hyped as
hell chainsaw man was meant to be his
magnum opus taking everything he's
learned from previous works and
perfecting it chainsaw man was meant to
be the outlier of Shonen Jump doing
things its own way chainsaw man starts
off like a pretty standard Shonen you
could be forgiven for getting a slight
feeling of deja vu watching a spunky
teenager on the brink of death making a
contract for the devil to gain devil
powers only to be picked up by an
organization that hunt said Devils under
the pretense that they can keep an eye
on him and won't kill him as long as
he's assisting in hunting other Devils
then we find out there's a super strong
devil that they have to hunt by looking
for his body parts which is really risky
because like any devil who's consumed
some of those body parts is a super
strong s-tier devil and you're like wait
a minute this is just Jiu Jitsu kaisen
again but that's where the similarities
end chainsaw man is a typical Shonen in
the same way that Stephen King's It is a
children's show about a funny looking
clown it is brutal disgusting raw it is
metal as [ __ ] it pushes the edge of what
it even means to be a Shonen action show
in the first place you look at some of
these scenes you see what these
characters do and you think
you know
that's not what Goku would do when we
first meet denji he is what's the
technical term for this again a broke
ass [ __ ] due to some unfortunate
circumstances he lives every day just to
survive drowned in debt a bottom dweller
of society he sold his left eye a kidney
one of his nuts yes his nuts just a
scraped by living on a slice of bread a
day I mean good Lord someone get this
boy some box suit
there you go boxy that was that was a
free one for you but this immediately
sets the tone for just what kind of
world this is Naruto Demon Slayer my
hero these are words where some pretty
hardcore [ __ ] can happen if you lay it
out on paper yet somehow everyone seems
to have come out squeaky clean tanjaro
had almost his entire family brutally
murdered and yeah he's still like oh I'm
gonna be a good boy I'm gonna be the
best boy I'm gonna empathize with all
the demons I'm gonna make the world a
good place [ __ ] you saw your mother's
bloody corpse how are you more mentally
stable than me remembering I got my tax
returns due in two months Shonen
protagonists have always been about
preaching that good moral work hard
train hard be a good person aspire to be
something great everything that denji
isn't the man's been through hell and
just wants to live in mild Comfort while
copying the Casual feel along the way he
doesn't have any Grand aspirations he
doesn't want to fight for what is right
he's not The Honorable innocent safe
protagonist we've gotten used to while
Goku is out there being like sell I want
you to power up to your final form so we
can have a fair and honorable fight
Genji is here like finishing move delete
bloodline well that's the thing that
well that's the thing though but that's
the thing that makes him interesting
okay
no this is not the way Genji God please
Benji for the love of God well that's
the thing that sets him apart and makes
him interesting and this is something
that's pervasive throughout every single
cast member in chainsaw man when you
agree Aki yeah totally agree everyone
here stands up from the typical
characters you see and I'm not talking
about in that usual anime way you know
sometimes you watch these animes and you
see these characters that are like look
at me I'm so quirky look at this weird
thing I do isn't it so weird are they so
weird and quirky I'm not like other
anime characters and then the super word
Quirk turns out to be something like
look at me I sit funny people in
chainsaw man are just actually weird
like I don't know puking in a guy's
mouth and then he swallows her and then
you try to sleep with him five hours
later
everyone here has a few screwsleys but
it never comes at the expense of their
character all too often in anime we see
these characters that are distinguished
by their weird quirks and even if they
have some depth to them it always comes
off as cartoonish the anime-esque
[ __ ] we've all gotten accustomed to
and one thing I've got to give props for
is despite how bad [ __ ] insane these
guys are they all still feel like people
everyone is just broken in some way like
they're all missing a different piece to
make them normal they're not cartoonish
they're just [ __ ] weird and that
absolutely works the Dynamics the Antics
the banter the cast is just so
entertaining together like there's a
scene where a bunch of devil Hunters are
trapped in this building possibly for an
eternity waiting for death one of them
has a panic attack one of them starts
freaking out and goes full yandere
They're laughing at each other denji
falls asleep two of them decide now is
the best time to pick up smoking power
starts spouting up that she's gonna be
prime minister and raise the sales tax
to 100 and I'm sitting here being like
what the [ __ ] am I watching chainsaw man
could be a sitcom and it would still
work it's like watching the cast of
Always Sunny if they were stars of a
Shonen action show are they [ __ ]
yeah would you be friends with them
probably a bad idea is it just hella
entertaining to see how they operate in
the situations they find themselves in
yes [ __ ] it's all great stuff even if
the structure is a bit reminiscent the
previous shonins we've seen that is
until this guy shows up and that's when
things really start revving up this is
the moment when chainsaw man really
starts showing its true colors within
the space of 20 minutes that shifts from
first gear straight to fifth gear looks
you dead in the arm goes you stupid
[ __ ] did you really think you knew
where this was going you feel like a
dumbass for forgetting the type of world
this all takes place in it is a cruel
ruthless place where your entire life
can change in one instance one bad
experience one unlucky encounter there
are no Second Chances and villains
aren't [ __ ] around here and just as
you start to think damn these bad guys
are pretty damn scary mahmas then like
[ __ ] only when you start to fear the bad
guys do you see that the good guys are
even more
and you don't know what to believe who's
good who's evil what's really going on
more questions emerge while nothing gets
answered and you realize the only thing
you really knew is that you didn't know
a damn thing this was the chainsaw man I
expected tusky Fujimoto is and never has
been a by the books guy it's like he
lured us into a false sense of security
then was like all right you've had your
fun now I'm die thank you forever the
more episodes I watched the faster I
click on the next episode button and my
only gripe is that it feels like we've
only just begun 12 episodes feels
brazily short for the story that
chainsaw man has set up which begs the
question am I just gonna read ahead in
the manga no because what I'm doing is
watching the anime then reading the
manga yeah that's right you heard that
correctly I'm reading the manga second
how does that make you feel manga
readers does that make you feel
uncomfortable uneasy maybe I'll mix it
up maybe I'll read a few chapters ahead
and then let the anime cat jump maybe
I'll reach up to 70 other context maybe
I'll just translate it all into Braille
and consume it that way yeah I don't
know why I was going with this anime
it's just my medium of choice there's
nothing to replace kensuke ushio's
hypnotic mesmerizing soundtrack The
Stellar animation or the voice sighting
that bring the chemistry these
characters have to life
[Music]
impressive very nice
and let's see the official Spanish dub
[Music]
um
but there are a few manga artists out
there like tatsuki Fujimoto and after
reading what the anime is covered yeah
he's a [ __ ] genius alright only so
rarely do you find someone who has such
Mastery of the page here is a man who
knows how to use manga to its fullest
potential which he does consistently if
you're someone who's never really
thought about layout paneling or page
composition I implore you to read any
one of his works and you are immediately
realize oh that's why it matters I know
this because I never did until I could
see how masterfully it could be used
well you know you could just watch my
other video where I go in depth about it
the work he's put into chainsaw man the
way he uses manga to convey ideas and
feelings is something that would be
impossible to translate into another
medium and so it doesn't but what Nuance
it loses it makes up for by adding its
own the anime takes its own approach in
telling the story colors are more muted
It characters look more realistic it
slows everything down not to pad out the
run time but just so you have time to
get absorbed into this beautiful world
and this has made some of the more
dramatic moments hit even harder it
isn't just reference Cinema it doesn't
just look cinematic it feels cinematic
almost as if this is an anime original
production not taking its material from
a manga I mean just look at something
like this
I [ __ ] love how it feels like this
devil was just deleted from existence
like it's what only an eerie
outerworldly creature can do and it was
just such a subtle thing that could only
be conveyed in anime form it really
seems like the team have put so much
thought into the visual storytelling
there are no lazy camera angles no
throwaway shots and instead of trying to
replicate what the manga has done
they've asked themselves what is
something that only we could do they
added a two-minute scene of Aki getting
ready in the morning and it is so
beautifully calming that gives us a
glimpse of who Aki is that was never in
the manga this is some Makoto shinkai
level of Vibes that absolutely did not
need to be done which shows that someone
there gives a [ __ ] and this isn't even
mentioning how good of a job they're
doing with the animation when people
think good animation they see a pretty
fight scene they think oh now this is
good animation wait 10 frames of CG
unwatchable but what they can gloss over
is that 17 other minutes of anime in
that anime chainsaw man simply looks
breathtaking in almost every single
frame fight scenes aside light there is
no reason why walking animation needs to
look this goddamn smooth or backgrounds
look so spectacular or hand-holding
scenes should awaken something in me
[Music]
and you know what I'll say it the CG
doesn't even look bad I think the real
reason it stands out points is just
because of how goddamn spectacular
everything else looks which experience
is better I don't know whatever meeting
me bloody prefer why not both
you have two separate versions two
separate Styles two separate approaches
to telling this fantastic story in a way
that utilizes their own medium to as
Highest Potential instead of one trying
to emulate the other and I can't even
begin to tell you how rare of An
Occurrence this is which is why it blows
my mind when I see complaints that this
scene doesn't look exactly how it does
in the manga or this isn't how the manga
depicted this one thing we have a
chocolate cake and a chocolate ice cream
in front of us and people are unhappy
that it's not the exact same flavor of
chocolate and I'm like bro you have a
delicious ice cream and cake right in
front of you why are you complaining
chainsaw man is setting up for the
series fans said it would be and it hit
the jackpot of having an anime
production this good while in no way
replacing what the manga has done will
these 12 episodes live up to the insane
hype people said it would reach no but
we already knew that so the real
question is when the hell are we going
to get more of it
oh God
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month too Alpha
Sigma basil dysfunctional degenerates
iviedo Jeff lovados
misaka12315 Payne Patchett Pony Stark
waltergeist VT anyone else my patreon
for helping to spawn me for this month
and making this video possible alright
guys I'm gonna keep this short and sweet
this was the last gigguk upload of the
year and yes I'm busy watching all of
the anime in 2022 there is a lot to get
through this was a very very good year
for anime so I'm not going to keep you
here for much longer I hope you've had a
great 2022 I hope you have a Happy New
Year and I'll see you guys next year